patrice désilets est un pionnier du jeu
vidéo au québec depuis plus de vingt ans
il assiste à l'essor fulgurant de cette
industrie en juillet 97 chez ubisoft je
suis le tout premier employé qui est
arrivé le premier matin et on voit là on
était 10 au début un et personne n'a
pensé je me suis aimable on n'allait pas
comme ça doit faire des jeux il ya des
gens qui font des jeux est maintenant au
québec mais c'est un peu reconnu que ben
oui c'est un vrai métier
et comment montréal est le cinquième
pôle mondial du jeu vidéo
l'industrie compte 10000 emplois au
québec plus de 230 entreprises et génère
des retombées de plus de 145 millions de
dollars
tout ça grâce à bernard landry et ses
tables du multimédia ne s'enseigne pas
encore dans les universités c'est qu'en
1996 bernard landry alors ministre des
finances a lancé le crédit d'impôt pour
la production de titres multimédias qui
permet aux entreprises du secteur de se
faire rembourser jusqu'à 37 et demi pour
cent du salaire de leurs employés
une mesure pour le moins audacieux 1,96
c'est quand même comme industrie l'on
parle du premier playstation y avait
vraiment un essor qui s'en venait mais
de penser que éventuellement ça ça
puisse devenir quelque chose de gros
pour vraiment être visionnaire dès
l'année suivante
ubisoft s'installe à montréal la
multinationale française a depuis
investi des millions de dollars à
montréal québec et saguenay un géant qui
profitent du crédit d'impôt tout comme
les employés qui se forme chez eux et
après le parti donc là ça vient des
sièges sociaux bien québécois payent les
impôts aussi qu'on travaillait déjà ici
c'est le cas de patrice désilets un
ambassadeur du québec aujourd'hui
reconnue mondialement
ici sébastien desrosiers radio canada
montréal